tell your story
if you only have one shot to make an
impression on a new potential client the
best thing you can do is not pitch them
but tell your story because it's
authentic because they'll listen to it
because it's real
and because it's something that nobody
else is doing
i got a question today from uh
one of my readers
rajiv hope i pronounce that properly
who's a life insurance agent and he has
a great opportunity ahead of him a
company came to him and basically he won
a chance to do a 30-second video
that they're going to shoot and produce
for him and he wrote in to say what
should i talk about in this video my
best advice for you for that 30 second
clip your one chance to make an
impression and have a professional image
out there is to tell your story
don't pitch some insurance product don't
go on about the benefits of using life
insurance you have one chance to make a
lasting impression and it's gonna come
from telling your story
when you tell your story people relate
to you more they like you they know you
they trust you they want to learn more
about you they feel like this is
somebody
who i can relate to
and when people can relate to you
they're more likely to buy whatever
product or service it is that you're
selling don't lead
with the product lead with yourself
especially when you're in a hugely
competitive industry listening life
insurance there's nothing that you're
selling that i can't get from somebody
else that's the nature of the beast
you're in a heavily commoditized
business and the best way to stand out
the only way you're gonna stand out is
throwing more of yourself into your
business
why did you start this company what are
you trying to accomplish
why do you love this what excites you
about this company let that shine
through
if you're excited and you're passionate
and you're honest and you're real
people will be drawn to you
and they'll want to work with you
if i was going to do something if i had
a quick pitch
i might do something like this
hi i'm evan carmichael i believe in
entrepreneurs
i had my first company when i was 19
years old i was all excited to start
this business up and soon discovered it
was way harder than i thought it was
going to be
and i thought about shutting down almost
every day i was making 300 a month and
couldn't survive and had to tell my
friends that i couldn't go out to dinner
with them
mostly because i couldn't afford it
i made it through i was one of the lucky
ones
eighty percent of businesses failed but
i made it through and now i teach
entrepreneurs how to do it
i'd love to help you if you want to do
something different in this world if you
want to start a business not just
because you're trying to make a lot of
money but because you see a different
future and you want to have an impact
then i want to help you
and i look forward to hearing from you
something like that okay that was just
spur of the moment i don't know if that
was 30 seconds however long it was but
with some practice
you can make it amazing
tap into your story
why you started this what you hope to
accomplish make it real make it
authentic and people will be drawn to
you
now this is really hard for anybody
who's first doing video it's super super
hard
i remember my first videos were terrible
you go back on my youtube channel you'll
see how bad they were
it's really nerve-wracking and the best
advice i can give you is really prepare
in advance so don't memorize a script
because that never works
you'll be looking into the camera like
this
and then trying to look off to the side
or trying to read something that's just
above the camera it makes you look like
you're not actually reading
you could tell
practice your pitch have something
written down practice it over and over
and over and over again but when a time
comes time to actually delivering it get
rid of the actual script
stop trying to memorize
go with what feels right
and try to ignore the people who are in
the room filming you because it is
nerve-wracking just talking into a
camera
and try to imagine your customer your
potential customer in front of you and
the message that you want to get out to
them you want to touch them in this 30
second opportunity
so practice practice practice
hope you guys enjoyed this video if you
do like it please give it a thumbs up
below it always makes me want to do more
for you and i want to hear what you have
to think please leave a comment below if
you agreed with my opinion here or if
you have a question for your company
leave it below and i'll make a video
response thank you so much and i'll see
you soon